joining me here on the rich ozone show
is uh one of our favorite guests
uh from his days as coaching with the
philadelphia eagles and
uh back here on the show fresh off of
the louisiana monroe pro day
where his son josh took the field uh
doing tight end drills under this man's
watchful eye he is doug peterson how are
you coach
hey i'm bill fine rich thank you so much
yeah it was a fun day yesterday to be
with uh
a few of the players obviously my son
out there it's first time i've really
had to
to to be to be actually on the field uh
with him so it was a great it was a
great it was a great day so
uh but thanks for having me on of course
you got it so you went out there
and you ran the drills i saw some of the
video you were out there going
running the drills uh for your son and
the other tight ends that uh and others
that were out there correct
that's correct that's great i wanted to
just make sure that he um
you know put his best foot forward
obviously and and wanted to showcase uh
what he what he could do and and
uh some of the other players there so so
i put a little script together
you know about 14 15 routes for him and
uh i was able to
kind of coach him through it and uh did
a nice job okay and then obviously we
could tell
he was your son when he put up 19 reps
of 225 in the weight room right doug
well that's not my that's that didn't
come from me because i didn't put up 19.
you did not back in your day you never
put up 19
is that how is that not even close not
even close
i think i think back then all i had to
do was 185 not 225
so that's uh it's a big difference oh my
gosh
i i saw that number that's a that's a
whopping fine number though
19 reps so how did you think he did i
mean because you you you clearly know
what scouts look for and what uh talent
evaluators are looking for what's your
what's your
first blush opinion here yeah i mean you
know i obviously
you know take the take that had to take
the dad hat off for for a second just
kind of watch
watch as a uh you know as a as a scout
or a coach and and
i thought he i thought he did well you
know i mean there's obviously some
things he can
continue to improve and work on but i
thought that
the bench press you know 19 reps was
really solid um
he's been training extremely hard to to
obviously
uh you know get to that get to that
point and and
um he he did a nice job and the routes
and the skills outside
i thought that's where he was going to
be able to showcase you know his talent
just a little
bit and and some of the things that he
did um you know at louisiana monroe and
he was able to do that so i thought
overall he
did a really nice job and you know to
have i
think there was anywhere from 23 24 25
teams you know present yesterday i
thought was uh
was good not only for for him and then
the players that worked out but but for
the university as well
for the program yeah the number i saw
was 25. were were
any of your uh eagles friends out there
uh as well yeah yeah yes yeah sean
heinlein
the scout for the eagles who who kind of
scouts this area
um was there and got to see got to see
him and visit and catch up with him and
see how he was doing and then
several others that i've you know met
through the years through you know the
combine or
uh other other workouts whatever we're
there so it's good to kind of catch up
with some of these guys
that's so cool that's cool doug peterson
here super bowl 52 champion head coach
on the rich eisen show uh let's get into
um
uh what some of the matters that are
still at hand with you
and the and the eagles um when
when you were in the draft room and
jalen hurts or jalen hurts was selected
and there was no draft room obviously
there was
the pandemic what was the thinking of
drafting jalen hurts
in philadelphia coach well he you know
my philosophy has always been and i
really honestly have learned this
throughout my career
um you know coaching and not only being
a head coach but also an assistant coach
being under you know coach reed
and and whatnot but you know we're
always continuing to look to to add
value to that talent to the roster you
know in the quarterback position
obviously is a
um is no exception you got to continue
to you know have
you know have two i think you got to
have two guys you know and and and
to be able to play in this league and um
jalen was there and
and we've i i spent a lot of time
watching him
you know the whole the whole spring and
and um you know really
really had an opportunity to to help our
roster and
and really look look at adding that that
uh that depth
that we needed at the position at the
time and so you know it's an opportunity
for us to take him
and um you know not for any
immediate future but but to have to have
a solid
you know number two and obviously we had
nate sutfeld too that was competing for
that role and
and uh just wanted to add that um you
know that that other element uh to to
the roster and so we were able to take
uh take jalen there in the second round
well i mean that certainly dovetails
with this philosophy
uh that that was uh borne out and the
fact that you know the philly special
trophy
is you talking to number nine you know
what i mean like that that's the
that's the second quarterback right
there so the sense and as you know
there's so many narratives that are out
there that i'm i'm wondering if you
could
uh either put to rest or or add some
more to is that
starting with the drafting of jalen
hurts kind of uh
didn't sit well with carson wentz at all
um and uh uh is that true is that a is
that a
uh a proper rationale to look at it
yeah i mean you know obviously i i don't
want to you know put words in
carson's mouth obviously but i can i can
just comment maybe even say that that
i you know if i were the starter um and
they drafted quarterback
you know my team drafted quarterback
that that high you know in the draft
i'd want to know why you know but but
the thing too is
is is you know we also communicate with
with guys and and want to make sure that
that everybody's on board and so having
those common conversations with players
even even with carson going into the
draft that there's a chance that
you know we take a quarterback and just
just being open with with him and
and look i i i wouldn't expect him to be
you know completely satisfied what we
saw around the league you know with
other teams
um you know you look at green bay and
and what they did there
you know in the draft last year and and
whatnot but you know again it's just
it's it's it's something that listen
it's uh
sometimes the quarterback position i
think kind of
sometimes i don't want to say it it gets
overlooked but it but it's
sometimes if you have a player there if
you have a starter
in that role you know you could you kind
of skip over it's okay we're good in
that position well
you can't just say you're good at that
at any position on your roster you got
to continue to
evaluate and add at that depth and that
competition that you want and
and so we were able to we were able to
pull the trigger on him and
and bring him into philadelphia and so
um with with carson
um you you had a conversation with him
prior to the draft and then after the
drafting of jalen hurts but he's still
the starter there
and to the right right so and so he's
still the starter there and
i mean you stuck with him a long time
you know coach you stuck with him
quite quite a long time during the
season and now i'm hearing we're hearing
uh after the season that you and he had
such a deteriorating relationship you
didn't speak to each other for
weeks on end is that is that a
a true assumption as well you know
carson carson in in in
was going into the 2020 season as as our
guys are starting he's the one we
drafted in 2016.
you know he was the one that we were we
were going to hang
you know hang our hat on and and and
build
build the franchise around and and and
so going into the season
he was the guy and you know things just
began to
um slowly kind of unravel i think with
the entire football team injuries began
to
creep in um you know we lost a couple of
close games
you know things things just started
going a little sideways for us and then
and then i had to make a decision
you know to to to bench him to put him
on the on put him on the side i had to
do something to
generate a spark generate you know um
a win uh the best the best we could and
and so i made i made the decision to
uh you know you know put him on the
sideline and start
uh start jailing and you know obviously
we we came out we i think we won our
first game with jalen and then uh
ultimately lost the last two or three
games there but
you know i i i it's it's funny because
there has been a narrative out there
that that you know he and i
um didn't speak but but we had
we had conversations early on even when
i was making this decision i want to
make sure that he was
fully you know uh prepared and and
understood where i was coming from in
making this decision
you know not just for him but for the
entire football team and
and you have to do that from time to
time and
and you know i i look back on it now and
and you know i would have done the same
thing
that there's nothing i wouldn't have
changed uh in my decision making you
know to help our football team
win again because we we weren't playing
well i mean and it's not
i said this many times too in in press
conferences and interviews
where you know i've always said it's not
about one guy i never you know there's
11 on offense defense a special team so
it's never about one guy but sometimes
when
when the quarterback you know that's
that's the position that people look at
right and that's the position that
okay i gotta i gotta make a decision
there and let's see if i can't generate
a spark and so that that's what i did
and um you know uh we continued to talk
throughout
you know the rest of the the rest of the
year and i i'd listen
if i were carson i'd probably be upset
too you know and that's just that's just
the nature
of of you know of sport that's the
nature of competition
um and and you know i wish him
nothing but the best and and uh continue
to look forward to following his career
in the future doug peterson here on the
rich eisen show and jalen hurts look
terrific
i mean he and he's a he's we had him on
uh
coach we had him on prior to your
drafting him and i said what is what is
it
what are you gonna what's the team gonna
get when
when they draft you and he's like i
wanna be the dog i wanna be the guy that
people depend on i wanna be the
the leader and it just comes out of his
pores and his whole
story you know what happened to him with
in alabama and tua and then going to
oklahoma and
he i think he's got the the thick skin
that you personally know you have to
have
to compete and succeed in that town and
so what what do you make of the the
story again that
that um that uh jeffrey laurie the owner
there
wants hertz is the guy and doesn't even
want like let's let's make him
successful
he's currently the only guy on the
roster uh at the position
in philadelphia what do you make of that
right now yeah coach well i mean i
i that's that's what drew that's what
drew me to
jalen hurts obviously was that wasn't
just exactly what you were saying
um you know i i you talk to his coaches
you talk to
you know the the people that are close
to him and and i mean this guy is a
uh he's he's a winner um he wants to win
he wants to put in the hard work and he
wants to put in the preparation and the
time to to be successful and
and it's just honestly it's the same
things we saw and and still see in
carson lantz i mean it's the same type
of mentality and
and jalen jalen's gone through
what carson went through last year you
know in alabama he got he got bent for
two
and you know and then he came off the
bench and
and won a big game for for alabama and
then obviously goes to oklahoma and has
a really good career there and leads
them into
you know the success that they had but i
i think i think this guy
um can can just use that he uses that as
motivation he uses that
um as his sort of fire uh burning desire
to to be successful
you know on and off the football field
and i i've seen
uh reports here recently that he's he's
working out with guys and throwing and
you know and wanting to learn and want
these are
these are conversations he and i had
when he was starting at the end of the
season he was he was
always coming to me and asking you know
how can i get better how can i improve
and
this is just who he is and and um you
know i just think he's got a bright
future ahead of him
doug peterson here on the rich eisen
show do you sit at any point in time
look uh you you're there's an
embarrassment of riches you got that
ring
the proverbial no one will ever take it
away from you right
your football life before all that uh
the fact that you got to spend a week
with family and coach your
son my goodness at a pro day in front of
25 nfl teams
you you obviously have so much to be
happy about and proud of and so on but
do you ever sit around and say
what the hell just happened like you
know i mean
honestly like it's you're three years
removed from holding the trophy and
smiling and
and people you know they're having a
grease you know street lights and street
lamps in philadelphia
to keep people from climbing them and
like do you ever sit around and say what
the hell just happened
doug i have um you know these
these past probably two months um you
know
since since mr lurie and i spoke last i
mean
i i i do wonder you know but but i
honestly i
i i kind of go past that i i think about
the good times i think about
the the 17 season the team we had i
think about
the leadership on that team and you know
winning a championship winning a super
bowl that's why we get into this
business is to win championships and and
that's what mr lurie hired me to do was
to win
you know win a super bowl or hopefully
multiple super bowls right in
in in philadelphia and um you know
they got that done and and so i look at
those moments and and say you know what
that's that's what i'm the most proud of
and that's what i can obviously hang my
hat on and
i know things happen for a reason i
understand it and maybe i don't
understand it
you know it kind of goes the other way
too but but i'm not gonna dwell on
a lot of the negative right i'm just
gonna sit there and and now look back on
on my time my five years in philadelphia
and the the
the relationships i've built and of the
a tremendous fan base who
still reach out to me today and you know
just
thank me and the team for you know
the championship and and what we brought
to that city and
um you know and and so i those are the
those are the things i think about
probably more than anything
and then i can kind of go out you know
on a little bit of a high note i guess
in philadelphia and be remembered for
that
did you have any shots at getting back
in the hc gig this
this january like after everything
disintegrated in philadelphia did you
get a call or
an opportunity or today you know i had a
through my agent talking and doing some
different things there were there were
some
some small opportunities but i just you
know um
was was thinking about my next steps and
what i was going to do and
and um you know i just i just didn't
want to rush back into
into another another opportunity another
head coaching
uh situation i really wanted to sit back
and really analyze the last five years
and and you know if uh if my future
brings another head coaching opportunity
um
you know obviously that's that's gonna
it's gonna make me a better head coach
in the future
uh because of what i've been through and
what we've done and
knowing how to win a championship and
how to you know help
build a roster that that did that and um
those are the things that i've thought
about you know the calls that i've
that i've taken and opportunities to be
a coordinator
you know um even even this year in 2021
and thinking about all of that but
uh you know my heart is is set on
becoming a head coach again and that's
that's going to be my focus yeah that
was going to be my question which is
kind of dumb though because i know i've
seen him i i see mariucci still like get
on his you
put his hands on his knees lean over and
talk to refs like he
you can't get out of your blood you know
what i mean so so you do want to get you
you do want to put the headset back on
and be an hc in the nfl
again i do i really i really do um i
really do and and i know that these
these five years in philly have have
really kind of
um i think paved the way for me you know
and and how to how to assemble the staff
how to
how to to to run an organization how to
lead a football team and
and um you know how to how to work hard
how to how to prepare and and
um you know put guys in positions and to
win games that's
that's what it's all about so i do have
that desire to you know to do that again
one day and that's that's my goal
coach really appreciate the time
congrats on having that moment with your
son out on the field yesterday that's
what we call
all kinds of cool that's like that's uh
you i have a sign here in front of me
that says best dad ever i got it from my
kids you're coming for my title i mean
you know what but i can handle it you
know i feel like i've got uh
i've got my resume pretty deep on that
front too but congrats on all that yeah
and i appreciate the time i appreciate
the time you're getting on the horn and
talking about a bunch of stuff that
that leaves a lot of people's head
scratching um and um
and i appreciate you doing that thank
you you bet rich thanks so much for
having me on and now it's a great time
yesterday and uh i'm gonna i'm gonna
continue to focus on josh and hopefully
uh
watch his career this uh this summer
hopefully this fall
thanks again for having me you got it i
look forward to calling out his name
during nfl network's draft coverage
uh at the end of next month great yeah
that'd be great i'll
i'll give you a little shout out i'll do
that when that happens
you take care thanks for the call you
got it that's doug peterson right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here